à la ferme des emplois fictifs du rpr a
entre autres été à l'origine de la
réforme du mode de financement des
partis politiques en france aujourd'hui
une entreprise ne peut plus verser de
fond un parti la transparence est le
maître mot dans les différentes
formations mais le contrôle à 100%
semble bien difficile stefan grand
nathalie berthier il gère les cordons de
la bourse ump eric woerth est un
trésorier comblé parce que l'argent ne
manque pas dans les caisses de son parti
mais en revanche des années rpr des
affaires il ne veut pas en parler il ne
jure d'ailleurs que par la transparence
actuel trésorier d'un parti politique
aujourd'hui c'est essentiellement un
contrôleur de gestion c'est à dire
qu'ils vérifient que le budget de
dépenses
est un budget qui est adapté à vos
recettes donc il fait très attention
comme dans toute association à ce que on
ne dépense pas plus que ce que l'on
gagne le financement des partis est
effectivement organisé par la loi depuis
plus de 15 ans les résultats des
législatives représente 90 % de leur
budget et s'est rapidement le jackpot
une voix exprimées rapporte environ 1
euro 60 à chaque partie le don des
entreprises est interdit à ce jeu très
lucratif l'ump a reçu cette année 33
millions d'euros le ps 19 ennemi le fn
et l'udf un peu plus de 4 millions
d'euros au ps on ne veut plus parler non
plus des affaires passées seul le
présent compte
quelqu'un qui veut frauder peut frauder
mais il sait qu'ils fraudent il sait
qu'il n'a pas le droit de toucher
d'argent des collectivités locales
directement ou indirectement
il sait qu'il n'a pas le droit de
toucher de l'argent d'une entreprise
directement ou indirectement
mais c'est pas parce qu'il est apte à
vis de volée qui ne peut pas y avoir
deux voleurs la course aux fonds
supplémentaires serait elle pour autant
de l'histoire ancienne certes la loi
fixe les règles du jeu comptable mais
les niches de corruption potentiel
existe bel et bien et y arriver en
grattant un petit peu de postes
d'assistants parlementaires d'emploi de
cabinet dans les collectivités
territoriales on peut tenter aussi de
demander à des entreprises de vous
recruter effectivement telle ou telle
personne 7 c'est un c'est un risque qui
existe toujours aujourd'hui évidemment
il y a toujours des risques de
corruption individuel locale mais
l'enchaînement des affaires a eu au
moins un mérite à seniran parties les
relations des politiques avec l'argent